So here we have a narration on the
authority of Abu Hurairah.
[Arabic recitation]
alayhi wasallam makes a statement of
truth.
A truism, something that is
an
objective truth about the nature of this
dunya and its relationship to Allah
[Arabic recitation]
So listen to this narration. He says,
"Ad-dunya mal'unah.
Mal'un ma fiyha."
He says, "The dunya
and what is meant by the world the word
dunya?
Dunya
[Silence]
The word dunya
is either taken in the Arabic language
or originates
from
lowliness
because it is lowly compared to the
hereafter. It is inferior.
Or
closeness because the dunya to us is
closer to us right now than the
hereafter is currently.
And so it is referred to as the dunya.
Meaning the closer of the two
lives, the closer of the two existences
that the human being has.
Allah the the prophet
says in this narration that the dunya,
meaning the life of this world,
it is mal'unah.
Now, sometimes this word is translated
as cursed.
But, that is not what is intended here
by
mal'unah because
the dunya in itself is neutral. It's
neither good nor bad.
And
the dunya in itself, in and of itself,
is an inanimate object. It's not
something that has good or bad in it
a human being has good or bad in
him.
Rather, what is meant by al-la'n in the
Arabic language
is that which is far,
distant.
When the prophet
says here in this narration
that the dunya is mal'unah, it means
that it is far away from Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
It is distant from Allah. It is not
close to Allah.
Everything in the dunya is far from
Allah, but there are a couple of
exceptions.
So,
essentially, the dunya is far from
Allah.
And when we say far here, we're speaking
of figurative distance, a distance of
virtue.
Virtually virtuously speaking, it has no
virtue except the following parts of it.
So, he says,
except for the
remembrance of Allah, the mention of
Allah,
and
the acts of worship of Allah.
But, the question really is,
is the remembrance of Allah considered
part of the dunya?
The life of the dunya?
No.
As-salat, for instance, is it part of
the dunya?
No.
It is part of the hereafter, and it is
something that transcends
the dunya.
[Silence]
And so, except here really means is
translated to
however.
However.
So, the prophet is saying here,
the dunya, it is far from Allah.
However,
the remembrance of Allah
and the worship of Allah, these are
things which are not of the dunya. So,
they are close to Allah.
And then he mentions one more thing.
He says, "Wa'aliman
aw muta'aliman."
And furthermore, the scholar
and his students.
These things are exempt from being
distant from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So, we have
a dunya, all that's
in this world,
is
essentially
distant from Allah.
It is distant from Allah. It is not of
Allah. It is distant. It is further. It
is closer to us in proximity, but it is
further from Allah in virtue.
However,
that which we can partake in, which is
not of loss and not of the dunya,
is the remembrance of Allah and the
worship of Allah
and the scholar and his students.
Meaning those
people of knowledge
and the knowledge that they learn
and teach to others. And obviously, what
is meant by knowledge here is knowledge
of revelation, knowledge of the Quran
and Sunnah.
If a person learns anything,
whatever a person learns
of the dunya,
if they use their intention
and learn this thing,
let's say medicine or
you know,
mathematics or physics or any any skill
that is of the dunya, but they learn it,
but they use it and use that knowledge
for the sake of Allah,
then
those actions become an act of worship.
They are not worship in themselves, but
they become
rewarded because of the person's
intention.
But, the mathematician and the physicist
and the doctor and the
Once
the
death comes to a person,
once a person dies,
they leave these things behind. This is
very similar to wealth, money. It is
inherited by other people, and this no
longer is of consequence to this person.
This person moves on from this dunya
into a reality where those rules and
knowledge does not does not apply.
[Arabic recitation]
ta'ala
and you are learning now
men kitab ma jahilna wa an yudhakirna
minhu ma nasina
hikmatan minhu wa an yubarika lana fil
Quran al-Azim
wa an yanfa'ana bima fihi min al-ayat wa
[Arabic recitation]